foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together
we're the minimalists we're here with
malabama hi everybody CK Coleman hey hey
hey we got the rest of our team here as
well and coming up today on this free
public minimal episode we're talking to
a listener about her attachment to
clothing then we've got our lightning
round segment a live stream question and
a listener tip for you you can check out
the full two hour maximal edition of
episode 389 where we answer five times
the questions and we dive deep into
several simple living segments that
private podcast episode is out right now
at patreon.com the minimalists your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck let's start with our
callers if you have a question or a
comment for our show make sure you give
us a call
406-219-783 39 or email one of those
beautiful voice recordings to podcasts
that the minimalists.com our first
question today is from Jessica hi my
name is Jessica I am from northern
Vermont
um I live in New England which lends
itself to needing a little bit more
clothing like snow pants hats gloves Etc
I also work in home health so I wear
scrubs and t-shirts and sweatshirts so
my problem is I still feel like I have a
lot of clothes and I actually wear about
80 of them I read a lot about going
through clothes that aren't in your
hamper but most of my clothes regularly
are I don't necessarily have an
attachment to clothes as Fashion's never
really been my calling uh this causes me
to really like to wear things that are
kind of worn out and it feels more worn
in to me I just enjoy being comfortable
what I don't enjoy is kind of the
Mountain of laundry I have to do almost
every week and a full feeling closet I
recall I think at one point Josh sang
something along the lines of you may
wear all your jackets but does that mean
you really need six of them sometimes I
feel like yes all of my jackets you know
serve a purpose like I've one for work I
have one for skiing I have one for fall
I have one for spring
um and then I kind of feel overwhelmed
by having all of these items any advice
for somebody who ends up actually
wearing most of their clothing but also
sort of feels overwhelmed by the amount
but has a hard time letting go because
every piece serves some type of utility
let's talk about your attachment to
clothing
if it's overwhelming it's clutter
because let's face it your attachment to
physical things is not just physical
it's mental it's emotional it's
psychological if they're getting in the
way not just in your closet but they're
getting in the way of your mind then
it's clutter and Jessica I totally
relate with this because after I started
simplifying my life the first place I
started was my closet I often think it's
one of the easier places for folks to
get started because Ryan you've
mentioned this before the average person
throws away a certain number of pounds
of clothing every year oh yeah 81 pounds
of clothing every year even though 95 of
it could be reused or recycled I mean
it's it's crazy there's another study
that was done where uh basically six
percent of people admitted
they had or they said that they had worn
every article of clothing at least once
that everything in their wardrobe the 94
had had almost 300 worth of clothing
they had never worn
so most people like Jessica here have
clothes in their closet that they don't
wear and I would say with Jessica the
overwhelm because she talked about 80 of
it always wearing 20 never wearing it
like maybe that's the 20 she wants to to
focus on maybe that would relieve some
of that stress that she's feeling that's
right and what I've noticed because
she's right I did say yeah if you have
six jackets just because you wear them
we have something called the duplicates
rule just because you wear them doesn't
mean that's a great idea to hold on to
they could still be getting in the way
however I think there's a flip side to
that as well I own two pairs of jeans I
used to wear only own one pair of jeans
oh my God you're exposing yourself that
was actually the problem I got a hole in
the crotch
and I'm like I need to get these sewn or
whatever I should have a second pair of
pants so yes you might have six and you
wear all of them and it makes sense to
get rid of three of them or four of them
or five of them or all of them but also
maybe you need more than one another
thing she mentioned that she wears
scrubs all the time I love having a
uniform and you can have some variety
within a uniform as well you have a
bunch of different color scrubs if you
want to add some variety but it's okay
to have more than one thing that doesn't
mean you're attached to it you're using
these things because you find them to be
useful we say love people and use things
and Jessica I think you may not have the
same problem that you think that you
have I'm going to give you some
boundaries here in a moment but first TK
I'd love to hear what you have to say
for Jessica well this makes me think
about the phenomenon of the golden
handcuffs golden handcuffs aren't just
about high paying jobs that also happen
to be really stressful golden handcuffs
refers to anything that's actually
valuable but it makes you feel
imprisoned and so there are some things
in life that have value they have use
but they restrain Us in ways that we
really don't like so I can't tell you
what to do with your other things but I
can give you a question to ask the
question to ask is not are my things
useful but is my use of these things
creating more freedom in my life or
compromising the freedom that I really
want to have yeah yeah and what you're
doing there is you're helping someone
set up a boundary right I've got some
boundaries for you as well Jessica
download our free minimalist rule book
you can find it at the minimalists.com
it's right there at the top you can just
download it for free in that rule book
There are 16 rules for living with less
I want to cover two of those with you
right now and I've got some additional
rules now these aren't actually rules we
tricked you because these are rules that
are adjustable they're boundaries
they're tools for your own life
obviously the first one the seasonality
rule this works perfectly for clothing
think about right now it's springtime
when we're recording and releasing this
episode and so have I worn this item in
the last 90 days we also call it the
90-90 rule for this reason and if you
have worn in the last 90 days give
yourself permission to hold on to it
if you haven't though here's the next
question am I going to wear this in the
next 90 days and you've got to be honest
with yourself because you can say oh yes
yes are you actually going to wear it
and that covers every season right
because yes I wore my winter coat 90 day
within the last 90 days for sure I'm
gonna hold on to that okay I haven't
worn these shorts in a while but
Summer's right around the corner yes I'm
going to wear these shorts in the summer
and then I think she has some items Ryan
that would fall under our personal
favorite role the spontaneous combustion
rule oh yeah yeah that's uh yeah because
it's the easiest one to use like you can
just pick up anything pick up this pen
and be like all right this pen
spontaneously combusted how would I feel
um well I've got other pens so I
probably wouldn't go out and like
purchase it right away but I do use my
pen uh if it was my last pen I would 100
go and replace it so that's just a great
little litmus test for all your stuff so
yeah Jessica you can pick up any item of
clothing in your in your wardrobe and
ask yourself what happened what would
happen if this thing spontaneously
combusted what would I do and if you
would feel a sense of relief oh that is
a sign to let it go yeah a couple more
rules that aren't in that minimalist
rule book we have ones called I hate
that thing rule but it started out as
the I hate that shirt rule I call it
shopping in my own closet because what
will happen especially back in the day
when I had all of these different
clothes they were aspirational clothes
and I would have some shirts I really
really really liked I like this shirt
but I never wore it because it was a
little too nice to wear out on a regular
day or yeah you know what I thought it
looked great on the mannequin or I
thought it looked good in the store
under those particular lights when I got
it home and tried it on I didn't even
know I had love handles until I put this
shirt on or these jeans on what am I
doing every time I put it on I kind of
hate it and that is a sign for me every
time as soon as I do this now if I put
something on one time and I'm like oh
it's gone it's out of my house and it's
out of my life because now it's
overwhelming and it's getting in the way
now it has turned into a clutter if I
don't enjoy wearing that thing then I
give myself permission to let go through
the mannequins used to get me all the
time because everything looks so
form-fitting and I I it took me a while
to realize that they clip the clothes on
the back so they make it look
form-fitting that's what I do with my
clothes
oh I just I keep forgetting to buy the
clips I have all these sandwich Clips on
my back right now that's why I look so
amazing oh man that's awesome TK uh we
were talking the other day about the
didn't know Rule and this is another
rule I think really helps people with
their clothing if you walk into your
closet you pull out something you're
like I didn't know I still had this oh
yeah I forgot all about that
I mean imagine if that was a friend
right I didn't know I didn't know that
person
how would you feel about a friend who
forgot about you you know what I mean
hey one quick thing about aspirational
clothes ask inspirational clothes are
very valuable man if they fuel the fire
of the more fundamental aspiration which
is to do the work necessary to be able
to fit into them however if they're not
contributing to that they possibly can
get in the way sometimes it's the
opposite that can help you fulfill that
fundamental aspiration that the clothes
represent you put on that shirt that
fits in a way that reminds you of what
your body actually is
then you're dealing with truth you're
dealing with reality and that might
motivate you to change it yeah I think
it's a great point I think about Ryan
whenever we have done tours in the past
people would come out the best dressed
people have the simplest wardrobes uh I
think about our friend Courtney Carver
she has something called project 333 and
I think this helps a lot of people I
will put a link to it in the show notes
by the way and there's a book uh it's
called project 333 so I'll put a link to
that in the show notes and here's
basically how it works TK I'm not sure
if you're familiar with this but you
base you take you do a packing party for
your clothes remember Ryan did his
packing party in our last Netflix film
and and boxed up everything as if he
were moving well you kind of just do it
with your clothes you box up everything
except for 30 your 33 favorite pieces of
clothes and this applies to shirts jeans
underwear accessories shoes 33 items is
all you get and for three months so
you're not getting rid of the other
clothes you're just boxing up making
them inaccessible for three months you
have 33 pieces of clothing you you wear
for three months and so inevitably what
happens you always pick your favorite
clothes and everything else that is sort
of quirky or weird or I kind of like
that or I'm not sure or it's not that
versatile we put that in a box and after
those three months you realize like oh
I'm dressed really stylishly every day
because and I'm wearing the clothes I
enjoy so now as a minimalist all of my
clothes are my favorite clothes because
all the other things that weren't my
favorite are in those boxes and quite
often what happens at our events Ryan is
someone will show up and they'll mention
project 333 and they're always the best
dressed person at the event absolutely
like you have to pick your favorite
clothes you have absolutely no choice I
think it's funny though there's
something like in high school where in
grade school like I remember wearing
something two days in a row and I was
just like ridiculed all day long by
those little twerps
and and so that stuck with me yeah I
remember like in high school I literally
had uh 10 days worth of clothes and like
I would never you know I like had it
hanging in order when I was going to
wear them I could wear uh I had three
pairs of jeans I could like alternate
those that seemed to not like spark any
outrage in the high school Community but
this carried with me um past high school
and what I've realized is people adults
don't care if you wear the same outfit
um the what really sparked that was when
we first started down this road of
minimalism it was uh I think it was Nina
Yao yeah she was wearing the same dress
for however many days in a row for one
four years and no one said a word to her
yeah it was a red sweater yeah red
sweater yeah and no one said anything to
her so yeah it wasn't even something
that was you know inconspicuous like
black and denim or whatever like yeah I
think the same thing kind of happened to
Courtney Carver when she was doing that
like when she first did her challenge
she went to work and no one was like
you've seen me wearing a lot of the same
stuff if anything they're like man
you've been looking really good lately
yeah yeah a quick lesson on Style style
isn't as much about how much you own as
much as it's about how much you own it
when you look at these celebrities you
please don't try to convince me that
everything they wear is cute and cool
it's the way they own it that makes
everybody want to wear it which is why
you got to be careful when you say let
me get that shirt and then you look at
yourself in it you're like ah I was that
dude who looks so good and it's not the
shirt yeah Jessica enjoy the minimalist
rule book you can download it for free
at the minimalist.com Ryan what time is
it you know what time it is it's time
for the lightning round where we answer
your questions from Tick Tock yes indeed
you can follow the minimalist on Tick
Tock Instagram Facebook and Twitter at
the minimalist now during the lightning
round this is where we each have 60
seconds to answer your question with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response and we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share or pithy answers on
social media if you like you can find
those show notes at theminealists.com
podcast today's question is from Van
fleena ever since I was a teen I've had
a strong preference for wearing only
black clothing my boyfriend recently
bought me a red dress but I have a hard
time wearing it do I need to overcome my
preferences to live in peace Ryan
Nicodemus do you have 60 seconds of
wisdom for van fleena I sure do uh my
pythy answer is this
the house of your life cannot stand on a
foundation of compromised values now the
thing is with this red dress that this
girl does not want to wear that her
boyfriend really likes her being in
that's the question she needs to ask
herself is she compromising her values
because I'll tell you if Mariah got me a
blue shirt and was like hey
um will you wear this I really like this
on you and I put it on and I didn't like
it I would be like honey I really
appreciate that you got me this but this
doesn't feel right on me I don't feel
like myself in this and if she was like
just try it out just trying to even for
Mariah I probably would try I'd try for
a week and if I got compliments on it
and changed my perspective then maybe I
would continue to wear it that's how
much I love Mariah but for as much as I
love her and as much as I would extend
wearing that blue Sean blue shirt as
long as I could there might be a certain
point where I'm like it just ain't
working for me I'm sorry I love you I
gave it a chance and if she takes that
approach with with her significant other
than probably gonna he's probably gonna
understand I would take it even a step
further if Mariah gave you the red dress
hey can you imagine and maybe you love
Mariah so much but at some point you
would say hey it's unreasonable to ask
this of me right and it'd be easier for
you to say this is unreasonable with the
red dress right a little bit different
the blue shirts not that different from
what you're doing right now but to her
it does seem like the red dress is so
appreciably different from her black
clothes it's unreasonable for him to ask
her to wear it TK do you have 60 seconds
of wisdom for us
if you must be in conflict with others
at least be in harmony with yourself
there will always be people that have a
problem with the way you want to do life
what's most important is that you enjoy
the person that you decide to be your
preferences aren't there to be overcome
as if there's some kind of obstacle in
your way your preferences are there to
be healthfully expressed and if someone
is saying to you you don't love me or
you're not a good friend unless you
abandon the healthful expression of your
preferences
I'm tempted to say let that friend go
but I would at least give them an
opportunity to understand what Real Love
and Friendship Is by saying hey that
doesn't fit right on me that doesn't
feel right on me I love the hell out of
you and I would appreciate it if you get
that opinion of yours the hell out of my
life so we can get on with having a good
time together
yeah yes
and he did it under a minute ladies and
gentlemen for the first time in
minimalist history this is the first
time everyone over
to save my maximum like my maximum I was
working my way up to it yeah but I heard
the ding and I had to stop it
so I love what you had to say about
preferences so give me 60 seconds and
I'll
oh wax philosophical on it
clinging to preferences is a great way
to get dragged away from peace you're
not wrong for having preferences in fact
we all have preferences right but the
more preferences we bring out and then
we cling to meaning we're unwilling to
change our preferences when they don't
really matter to us at all I have this
strong preference I need to expose it to
the world yeah it reminds me of that
Meme I was showing Professor Sean this
morning or I've shown Danny as well and
it's this guy looking in the mirror and
says now get in there and make this
about you
that's great that's what we're doing all
the time we're making it about me me me
however here's what I'll say
if he is forcing you to wear this dress
manipulating you to wear this dress then
you don't need that kind of person in
your life who wants to change your
preferences for you
I think it's Dan Savage would say he
would say
dtmfa I'll let you all Google that
dtmfa if he is pressuring you and um I
saw this with my own my wife's wardrobe
um when she when she and I first met I
saw a picture of her the other day from
back in 2015 like when we first met her
and Ella was like one year old and
or maybe Ella was two at the time and
Bex looked like she was dressed like the
Hamburglar
she was wearing like the striped skirt
ing these things that she would never
wear today and it didn't look crazy it
just didn't look stylish at all Bex has
become so stylish over the last eight
years or whatever it's been since I've
known her but I never once said you
should wear this now I will tell her I
like the way this looks or that looks
really great she was wearing this outfit
yesterday I was like oh my God you look
amazing in that but it wasn't like hey
you'd look great in this you need to
wear this there's a distinct difference
in our disposition in the way we feel
because she felt compelled like pulled
in the direction of being more stylish
instead of being pushed in the direction
of being more stylish and now she's one
of the most stylish people I know
without ever being forced or convinced
that she should be more stylish yeah
yeah hey I want to say one last thing
about this phrasing here overcome my
preferences to live in peace
right because you don't ask yourself how
can I overcome my preferences when
everyone's leaving you alone you only
even ask that question when you're
thinking about must I overcome my
preferences to live in peace and what I
want to say is I don't think any of us
need to overcome our preferences to live
in peace we need to overcome our fears
towards having the difficult discussions
that lead to peace peace is not this
passive default State that's defined by
the mere absence of contention
disagreement and conflict peace is the
product of what we create by being
willing to take life's difficulties head
on when we Face the contrast and we say
I'm going to talk about it I'm going to
tell you how I really feel I'm gonna say
no to you even if that means we might
have a challenging conversation that
follows that's how you get to peace
that's on the other side of that yeah
Yes Man beautiful what a great
observation it makes me think like
preferences are kind of values in a way
really because I don't really value
Aesthetics like it's not something that
is a huge deal to me but it is a huge
deal to me for the clothes that I wear
and uh even though that is a preference
like yeah that is
I I agree with you it might be very
unreasonable especially if it's causing
uh if it's disrupting the piece in the
house like it is kind of unreasonable
for her partner to keep coming at her
and asking her to wear a red dress and
she's vehemently against wearing we have
a free values worksheet over at the
minimalists.com V you can download that
and in that worksheet it helps you
identify the four types of values and I
agree with you I think the surface level
values which are the third layer of
values they're sort of our preferences
and our preferences change over time and
so that portion of our values often
changes as well because the things that
were your preference when you were three
years old might be apprecially different
at 43 years old I don't know I still
wear Transformer underwear
hey I don't think her boyfriend is going
to be mad though it's just speculation
no I think it should say baby I I
appreciate the dress baby but I just
can't wear this this is just not me yeah
I think it's gonna be cool yeah that's
my guess yeah it'll be fine I think
you're right yeah and if he's trying to
coerce you into wearing the dress all
the time then that says something about
the dynamic of the relationship and it's
always okay to let go of someone who is
trying to coerce you
because coercion is not consent but also
convincing persuading manipulating those
things aren't consent either that's
unloving I want to check with our
patreon live stream here in a moment but
first real quick for right here right
now here's one or two things going on in
the life of the minimalist last weekend
we had a team building event we all went
out and shot each other it was so much
fun I still got bruises
just well this one right here do you get
any bruises oh yeah oh my God I can't
show you where they are though we'd have
to upload this to rumble or something
yeah so what'd you think to get your
first time paintballing yeah well I
can't confirm my personal participation
in it uh but you know one of my
observations is that uh Danny Unleashed
you know he's an interesting paintball
player that's all I'll say you know
there were certain players sometimes who
was calling for uh paint checks and
Danny's just shot him anyway so
no no no I tell you I'm not bitter about
it at all
the biggest lesson I learned from the
whole team outing is do not get into a
shootout with malabama oh my goodness I
don't know why I know it from the very
beginning like she had she had Game Face
from the very first time she put on like
her little uh mask before she like put
it over she's like ready to go her and
David make an amazing team and I'm so
glad that David has some Alabama to
protect him if anything ever goes down
she's a silent killer man oh she's an
assassin yes I heard everybody say I
thought she was out like everybody who
got shot by Bama said their last words
was I thought she was out and now I'm
out yeah she's just a silent killer oh I
did I didn't tell you this when we were
playing but the whole time when I was
hiding like I literally was like I have
to assume Mallory is right around one of
these corners and like that's how I
played the entire game like okay she's
she's right there I know she is so I was
playing paranoid the whole time
we did uh when we started we did three
on every everyone so it was like three
on nine or three on ten whatever the the
number was it was just me Ryan TK versus
everyone but I set up one rule I said
it's racist to shoot TK so we just won
every time it was super super helpful
I'll tell you Mallory's uh husband he
was like sliding into obstacles it was
amazing unbelievable and everyone did an
awesome job Jordan was out there
pretending he didn't get shot
I lit Danny up a bunch and he was also
like oh none of it hit me
all bounced off it's fine dude shout out
to Beulah yeah
I was helping her six foot seven husband
would show up so I'd have a big Target
that I could hit but uh yeah he was at
home watching Jeezy their son and uh man
what a beautiful time it was the weather
was perfect great time thank you all for
being a part of it one other thing Ryan
and I just got back from Georgia we were
at Georgia Southern University in the
mega Metropolis of Statesboro Georgia
which is a quick four-hour drive from
Atlanta right yeah it's not it's not in
the middle of nowhere
we actually had to Wade through a swamp
to get there they were awesome shout out
to all the folks over at uh Georgia
Southern University we got to speak
there uh they actually opened up to the
public as well I've never been
recognized more than in I think
Statesboro Georgia people were like
running out of the Starbucks and saying
the minimalist what are you doing in
town and they're like so uh I know you
were speaking here are you doing any
more shows while you're in Statesboro
I'm like yeah we're here for an entire
month we're doing a full residency me
we'd actually love to come to your
school if you want to hire the
minimalists to speak at your school your
college your organization you can find
all the details as well as a speaking
real a demo of uh speaking over at the
minimalists.com
speaking we'll put a link to that in the
show notes as well and we're going to
check in with the patreon live stream
Alabama what kind of questions you got
for us give us a good one we have a
question here from Joan I noticed that
as I release more things that no longer
serve me or my husband there seems to
always be more I'm not sure when I'll
ever feel done do you have any guidance
on this Ryan I love you were talking
about this earlier because Catherine
Morgan schaffler was on the show and she
talked about the root of the word
perfect is perfect which means per and
for Sarah completely done is essentially
what perfect means and so will you ever
be perfect and the answer is you were
born perfect already all of the things
that you've heaped on to your life to
add value they may have added value but
at some point they may imperfect your
life I think it's most uh most
noticeable in our clothing because
Trends happen and things go out of style
and you're like oh these oversized
silver tab jeans what am I still wearing
these or Ryan's Janko jeans from our
high school days I was my dad would
never allow me to buy Django jeans and
in the moment they might have been
perfect for that moment but if
something's perfect for the moment
doesn't mean that it's perfect for right
now and so clinging to it Imperfects you
in a way now will you ever be completely
done no I wish you would I wish you
could get down to the 100 or 1000 or 10
000 or 14 000 items you could own to
have a complete life but if something
ceases to add value then you're still
going to have to let it go otherwise it
will turn into clutter tomorrow yeah and
this expectation that there's a
destination you're clinging to that
expectation you can let that expectation
go and be happy where you're at and
enjoy the enjoy the ride no limits to
clinging
[Music]
we'll check back in with the patreon
live stream here in a moment but first
i'm Alabama what else you got for us
here's a minimalist Insight from one of
our listeners hello Josh and Ryan my
name is Vandy Bender I am calling from
Lincoln Nebraska I'm calling today
because I have a great solution for what
to do with an old wedding dress
especially if it's kind of outdated and
not likely to be worn again the
hospitals in my area have a wonderful
program that volunteers who take old
wedding dresses and make burial gowns
for infants I think this is a great way
to honor these children and I know it is
something the family is mourning the
loss of a child will find Value in
all right y'all that's our minimal
episode for today we'll see you on
patreon for the full two hour maximal
edition of episode 389 which includes
answers to a bunch more questions like
what can I do if I regret letting
something go how could I be a minimalist
and have a hobby that involves crafting
how can minimalism help me create
work-life balance while still working
from home plus we got a million more
questions for the minimalists also this
week a private minimalist home tour it
is the most minimalist and the cleanest
kitchen I have ever seen from one of our
beautiful listeners all that and much
much more of less and if you want to
hear all that check out the minimalist
private podcast at patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain access to all of
our podcast archives all the way back to
episode
001 and if you're still on the fence
here's a testimonial from one of our
lovely patreon supporters Paulette says
I love that you guys take yourself
seriously
but not too seriously that perspective
has changed my outlook on everyday life
that's why I love listening to your
private podcast every week thank you so
much Paulette if you leave here today
with just one message please let it be
this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it thank you foreign